in a previous video we introduced
ourselves to the idea of bonds and the
idea of ionic bonds where one atom
essentially is able to take electrons
from another atom but then because one
becomes positively charged and the other
becomes negatively charged they get
attracted to each other now we're going
to go to the other end of the bonding
spectrum where instead of stealing
electrons from each other we're going to
share them let's say we're dealing with
two oxygen atoms
so
let me draw one oxygen here a neutral
oxygen has eight electrons total but six
of them are in its outer shell so it has
one
two
three
four
five
six valence electrons and the way that i
arranged them is i paired them up last
so you have these two valence electrons
that are not paired with another
electron now let me draw another oxygen
and i'm going to do it with a different
color so we can keep track of the
electrons so another oxygen right over
there also has six valence electrons one
two
three
four
five
six valence electrons
now
this oxygen on the left in order to
become more stable it would love to
somehow gain or maybe share two more
electrons and of course this oxygen on
the right it's still oxygen it also
would love to gain or share two more
valence electrons so how could it do it
well what if the oxygen on the left
shared this electron and this electron
with the oxygen on the right and the
oxygen on the right shared this electron
and this electron with the oxygen on the
left
well if they did that you would have
something that looks like this
you have your oxygen on the left
you have the oxygen on the right
and the way we show two electrons that
are being shared let's say these two
electrons are being shared is just a
line like this
this shows that there are two electrons
that are being shared by these two
oxygens and let's say that these two
electrons are also being shared you
would do that with a line like this and
then we could draw the remainder of the
valence electrons this oxygen on the
left had
outside of the electrons that are being
shared it had four more valence
electrons and then the oxygen on the
right had four more valence electrons
one two
three four
now what's interesting here is the
shared electrons these are going to
cause these oxygens to stick together if
they don't stick together these
electrons aren't going to be shared so
what we have formed here is known as a
covalent bond
covalent
bond and what's interesting is it allows
both of these oxygens in some ways to be
more stable from the left oxygen's point
of view it had six valence electrons but
now it's able to share two more remember
each of these bonds each of these lines
represent two electrons so this oxygen
could say hey i get to have one two
three four
six eight electrons that i'm dealing
with and the same thing is going to be
true of this oxygen on the right
now there are some covalent bonds that
are between not so equals so for example
if we're talking about water and if
we're talking about how oxygen bonds
with hydrogen
so if we have oxygen right over here
once again i can draw it six valence
electrons one
two
three
four
five and let me just draw the sixth one
right over there
and if i have hydrogen hydrogen has one
valence electron so let's say that's a
hydrogen right over there with one
valence electron maybe another hydrogen
right over there with one valence
electron
oxygen and hydrogen form covalent bonds
in fact that is how water is formed
and so what would that look like well it
would look like this you have oxygen
right over here you have these two pairs
of electrons that i keep drawing
and then this
electron right over here could be shared
with the hydrogen and that hydrogen's
electron could be shared with the oxygen
so that forms a covalent bond with this
hydrogen
and then
this electron from the oxygen can be
shared with the hydrogen that electron
from the hydrogen can be shared with the
oxygen and so that would form a covalent
bond with that other hydrogen
and now here once again oxygen can kind
of pretend like it has eight valence
electrons two
four six eight and the hydrogens can
kind of pretend that it has two valence
electrons but the one difference here is
that oxygen is a lot more
electronegative than hydrogen it's to
the right of hydrogen it's in this top
right corner outside of other than the
noble gases that really like to hog
electrons so what do you think is going
to happen here well the electrons in
each of these covalent bonds are going
to hang out around the oxygen more often
than around the hydrogen so the
electrons spend more time around the
oxygen you're going to have in general
more negative charge around the oxygen
and so you're going to have a partial
negative charge
on the oxygen end of the water molecule
and then you're going to have partial
positive charges on the hydrogen ends of
the molecules in case you're curious
that little symbol i'm using for partial
that's the lowercase greek letter delta
which is just the convention in
chemistry and so this type of covalent
bond because there is some polarity one
side has more charge than the other this
is known as a polar covalent bond polar
covalent
bond